yeah we're now on live chat
thank you all right good evening ladies
and gentlemen and welcome to this
meeting of the torridge district council
community and resources committee
my name is bob hicks chairman of the
committee
but tonight because i had an operation
last wednesday
and have to take trips to the loo about
every quarter hour 20 minutes
which i don't feel is a satisfactory way
to run a
meeting i would like to propose that my
vice chairman dermot mcguff
takes the chair for the evening
please automatic actually bob isn't it
if you can't do it the ch vice channel
i was hoping so yes yes
fair enough
sorry we do need to vote on that because
the chairs actually within the meeting
see oh right okay
read the small print eh
any other proposals
right we've still got to vote it
kirsty are you able to do the vote
please yes certainly thank you chair uh
councillor brenton
for councillor bright
or councillor bushby or
councillor christie councillor dart
i'll abstain because i'm sorry i only
just got into the meeting
thank you councillor hicks
um i do believe councillor hutchins has
given apologies today
um councillor hurleys has taken his
place so councillor hurley
thank you councillor james or
councillor laws or
councillor lock wall councillor what
uh magoff or
and councillor wiseman oh
thank you so that's eleven four and one
abstention chair
thank you over to you dermot okay
um i'd like to welcome the members of
committee this evening
and to the members of the public uh for
monday the 7th december
for the community and resources
committed me
item one on the agenda is apology
have we got any apologies for absence
please
thank you yes just um councillor
hutchins with
councillor hurley substituting okay
thank you very much item two on the
agenda minutes of the community and
resources committee meeting
held on the 19th of october 2020 pages 4
to 15.
i would go through these page by page if
you just bear with me
give me fat little thumbs working
page 4 page 5. page six
page seven chair chair
can i just early ask a question on page
seven please
yep go ahead it's it says on page it
says on page seven the chief executive
acknowledged the member's concern
referred to
councillors ford noticed a motion
regards the jet ski problem
there was a meeting taking place the
following day with the intention
that something will be done in place by
easter 21
did that meeting take place i guess it
did and what was the outcome of that
steve would you like to answer that
please uh yes thanks chair um yes that
meeting took
place uh sean myself councillor james
met with councillor ford
and councillor hayes down at appledore
the prime reason for
that meeting that day was to to look at
things on site
around the the campervans and any future
proposals for
jet skiing notes this evening uh
councillor ford's notice of motion
uh in relation to campervans parking at
church fields is on the agenda
so that's the outcome of that meeting um
in relation to the other notice of
motion around jet skis that will come
forward
to a subsequent uh community resources
committee
in time for easter thank you very much
okay guess early okay
okay page eight page
nine page ten
page eleven
page twelve page
13.
god this paper's tough
it's not copying on again is he
no it's way cool working on a roof all
day and your hands are cold page 14
accounts are locked now i'll just wait
to propose that we accept the minutes
after page 16.
okay page 15. so guess a lot you propose
i am yeah i'll second it
council brenton's second in and we'll go
to the vote there please
thank you chair councillor brenton for
councillor bright or councillor bushby
or councillor christie or
councillor dart
councillor hicks poor
councillor hurley or councillor james
or councillor laws or
councillor locke or councillor mcgough
or councillor wiseman
that's unanimous chair thank you very
much
okay move on to item three which is the
action list and that's
on page 16.
anyone got any questions for the action
list
okay do we have to vote in a state or
just note it
okay change
sorry councilman um yes just noted thank
you okay brilliant
okay move on to item number four then
please which is the public contributions
do we have any members of public wishing
to speak mr yes
oh look at that look okay item number
five which is the forward plan
and that's page seventeen councillors
anyone who got any questions on the
forward plan
anything like to be added to the forward
plan
just that three minute
oh all being good tonight aren't we is
that noting again stacy
yes yes just making sure in case you
want it in
okay lovely item number six
declarations of interest obviously
counselors you all know this
score any declaration of interest do so
when the item arises
uh item number seven the agreement of
gender between
part one and part two i see we do have
part two so you can move a proposal
okay and our second that rose against
the lock sorry
can we go to the vote please on that one
thank you chair
councillor brenton or councillor bright
or councillor bushby or
councillor christie or councillor dart
or councillor hicks
or councillor hurley or
councillor james or councillor laws
or councillor locke or
councillor mcgough or
councillor wiseman or thank you that's
unanimous chair
okay lovely thank you much item number
eight
urgent matters of information to be
brought forward with the permission of
the chair and the committee
mr hurst do you have anything to bring
forward
uh no chair i don't okay neither dwight
so we move on to item number nine that's
the notice of motion
the campervan overnight parking in
church roads car
park epidural and that's pages 18 to 21
and the we received a report from the
head of communities and places
sorry council devisement declaration of
interest
uh because we're going to be talking
about the night the charges for
campervans i think i'd best
remove myself from this discussion okay
thank you very much
any other counselors no
that's quite good it comes right in the
middle of the screen right thank you
very much
counselor haynes
councillor haynes sorry chad
what'd you like to speak on it's lahaims
you've muted yourself
sorry um is it going to be uh a vote
of verbal report first i'll wait till
then otherwise
um yes guys james as i just stated on
the thing that
i just read out it was the report to the
headed communities and places so we'll
go over to the report from the head of
community
places and then it'll be open to the
committee first members of the committee
and then to other councillors thank you
thank you chair um so the report you
have in front of you is hopefully
uh going to guide you through your
debate around councillor ford's notice
of motion
um i'm not sure if councillor ford was
on the call this evening um i think he
was intending to come along and
introduce it but if he's not
i'll press on um so undoubtedly in
previous years campervan parking
and our car parks has been a real
success um we've been
uh received lots of letters of
congratulations from
uh campervanists and others um but this
year there have been an extraordinary
amount of camper vans and i think
it's fair to say there have been some
management issues in epidural
um what uh there are three substantive
parts
to councillor ford's uh notice of motion
basically and if we move to the picture
tom
i can explain so on this bit of
fantastic graphic design work that i
prepared for you earlier on
uh councillor ford is proposing a
section of the car park to be set aside
for exclusively four camper vans and
that would be the yellow
area in the car park for those who
aren't familiar with it he's also
talking about
increasing the charge for overnight
stays currently set at five pounds
to 15 pounds and that only one night
stay would be permitted
and it currently we permit two so
in the report we've looked at how that
might be managed and have concluded that
we might be able to manage the issues
down there to
appease councillor ford and the local
community that have
made representation to him by doing
things in a slightly different way
so what we'd like you to consider when
thinking about this issue this evening
is whether instead of
setting aside part of the car park
exclusively for campervans
an area and that would be the area
marked in red we would change the
parking order to exclude that a
campervan parking in those areas so we
would actively enforce
and issue pcns for campervans parked in
those areas but permit it
in the rest of the car park now part of
the issue as i understand it from
councillor ford was that the camper vans
were parking all along
the riverside which is the area in red
blocking the view
and there's a pavement that runs along
the river's side of the car park
and or overhanging that area and if they
weren't parking in that zone then
obviously those pr those problems would
be
mitigated somewhat um camp fans
like to park in that area obviously
because of the view but also because
they are long vehicles and they do take
up more than one bay
in some instances and so what we would
say is that if they were
in the rest of the car park and
overhanging another bay they should
they should buy two tickets which is
currently the arrangement in the parking
order
we'd like to propose that perhaps 15
pounds
suggested by councillor ford is a bit
much and i think given that we provide
no facilities
it might be more reasonable to think of
a slightly lower charge
i totally concede that uh maybe there's
time for a review
and to increase the charging uh so we'd
suggest eight pounds
and that uh it's over you to you to
debate the length of stay like i say
currently it's two
two nights if you want to limit it to
one that's fine
the one thing i would consider or would
like you to consider if that's possible
police members is that
obviously this uh like i said before has
been quite a successful initiative it's
quite successful in this
initiative in a number of car parks um
we're only really debating arrangements
for church field car park i
i'm not sure uh that you would want to
consider
um excluding campervan car parking from
other car parks because it has been
quite a successful initiative although
the charge you might want to consider
across the the full car park estate um
so i just uh like to point out actually
in the first recommendation
that i have omitted to put after
approve it should say or reject i've
i've missed out reject in that line so
back to you chair thank you
lovely okay counselors before i go to
any members committee i see that council
of ford
had just logged in so i will go to
cancer ford straight away as this was
cancelled forwards
notice a motion council default over to
you
hello can everyone hear me loud and
clear yes we can
right great everything that
should be decided at toys should be
evidence-based and for the betterment
of the wider range taxpayer
everything has got a financial and
social cost
churchfield car park is the best car
park
by far in the ownership of colorado
council as regards of location and views
so it is only the car park i am talking
about
i'm the only one i know what i'm talking
about
we've got to get a resolution here what
i will say is the five
pound in 2014 in my opinion
was uh probably too low and it's right
on about the
uh federation of small business and all
that
fine i would suggest the people on that
panel does not live in ecuador
and hasn't seen the impact socially
without an apple door
now there's always a trade-off with
financial i've got a level
dependency or whatever and social gain
but when you actually block footpaths
you actually have uh camping fires at
halftime at night
i'm sorry it's totally out of order and
we
as councillors have got to get a balance
between financial and social gain and it
is difficult i accept that
it's not been monitored for years i
actually would say
the five pain in 2014 was too cheap
anyway i can simply say to you that
at the moment let's be brutally honest
um
and i do like a pint of beer two pints
is more than eight quid
just be brutally honest two points of
goodness is probably
ten quid 2014
five pound great as we got small
business all that yeah we can bring in
business and we haven't got the
infrastructure to deal with it
um we gotta get better than this
actually because we need tours i might
accept that not a problem
what would simply say to all councillors
by the way i didn't even use a
calculator because i don't need to
if you use compound 10 percent based on
five pound 2014 2021 will give you 9.76
um what i will say is to also the other
day
as regards sometimes irrespective
of our political leanings counselors
don't listen to officers and we uh we
refer to a plan application recently
where
whereby um usually you know chancellors
that would normally think
of their capsule officers did not they
chose to and i think they made the right
decision
i think it's a great report i accept
about changing the location
left running on right and evan i think
sean county's done a great job on that
one
but don't roll over here i still think
eight pounds too cheap i
also think two knights is wrong
you know it's mobile mobile homes they
meant to move
just make it available for other people
to come in we have
been bad as regards doing captain sites
um
you know some councils go on about and
we should have more
uh campaign sites and actually they're
voting on planning to close them down
and i can wheel it off but that's not
about that today so making the balance
here
and for christ's sake i actually think
we can
with a bit of common sense eight pain is
still
too cheap we should not be in
competition
with campsites which we have not got
enough actually
we've not done enough to embrace
campsites we've actually because a
planning application
shut them down let's get a balance
i would say in counsellors like say 10
compounds only 9.76 9.76
compound from 2014 to lower start
don't go any less than tenner i'm being
serious
i'm not rothschild i'm not i'm open i'm
not i would pay that
and i feel passionately about it we've
got to get it right with that i'll leave
it
but if i get an opportunity if the chair
can allow me
i want to listen to the debate and it
would be great
and really i think sensible if the chair
could allow me 30 seconds or a minute
after the debate and with that i'll
leave it
hey thank you very much council ford
council ford i would always allow you
time after the debate it was your
emotion that was the motion that went
forward
uh the first spit a long list there
counselors the first one was counselor
brenton
i did see you removed your hand i hope
it wasn't in frustration
no thank uh thank you councillor madoff
uh yes uh what i would like to do just
kick the things off is to
move the recommendations on page 21 or
at least
two three and four
move those because i think the officers
did a very good report here
they picked up on the concerns of
councillor ford quite rightly and i
agree with him about the fact that the
campervans
are in the wrong space in uh
churchville car park along the front and
i've been down there during the summer
and seen what they've been up to
and they do let the the side down i have
to say i mean i've got a campervan as
you know and
you know i've done wild camping and
camping car parks
across europe and in this country for
the last 30 years
but we've got to fit ourselves into what
is happening in the country
campervan sales were up by 12 in the
last 12 months
and they're going to increase even more
because of covid
it's going to be a very popular pursuit
and the people who buy them
are by and large middle-aged
elderly people like myself and we go
into towns and we spend money
on food you know restaurants and various
other things as well
that's why you need two nights if you
turn up on one night stay there
overnight you want the following day to
explore the area
and spend another night after you've had
a meal locally
so i don't think they're good for the
economy so we need to encourage them
and we've done a brilliant job with our
car parks in the
um camping spaces we've had because i
read the letters columns in the
3ms magazine which is the main journal
for campervan owners
and it's very complementary about all of
them the only
problem i have with it is it doesn't
mention torridge the fact that all these
good car parks
in appledore uh torrington
biddeford and westwood ho don't come
under that blanket umbrella but
that's by the bite the fact remains a
they get we get good publicity out of it
i'll tell you one thing it'll happen if
you don't if you don't get this right
we'll get
bad publicity and trust me the letters
will be in there
and there are areas in this country
where campervans won't go
because of the unfriendly reception that
they receive
on the continent campervans are welcomed
everywhere
because they bring in tourist money so i
think if we would get the campervans off
the
seafront off the front of there they
shouldn't be there in any case it is
wrong though there
apart from the other places and if we're
paying a lot of them are too long for a
car bay so therefore they have to pay
two lots of um
parking charges quite right that's not a
problem with that
i think eight pounds is a good fee that
fits in
with other car parts throughout the
country there are some that are free in
local authorities
and of course you go to france and spain
and that loads them are free in the
local authority ones but we're
we're not in that position and i do
think that as i say the officer report
is good
and extracting from that those
recommendations and i would happily move
those and i think we'll we'll get it
right
thank you chair thank you much
councillor brenton i'll move to cancer
to bush me next please
did i have a second by the way sorry mr
brenton you haven't
that's why i moved to canada okay thank
you chair
um a couple of points that i'd like to
make um
the the two nights i agree with
councillor brenton is probably
uh of benefit um you know as people
moving for one night it's
particularly if they arrive um you know
late in the afternoon or early evening
um so tune i i'm quite happy with that
um
the the the increase of three pounds
right
per night is far too cheap as councillor
brenton said
these are wealthy people a lot of these
fans are 60 to 80 000 pound a piece they
can easily afford
to pay um what i would consider to be a
fair charge there
and i would suggest 12 pound a night is
is easily affordable in the car park um
i would just take issue with one thing
that sean said in his in his report
that we don't offer any services we do
offer services
there's a hard standing and believe you
me when you've got a large motor caravan
particularly most of the the fiat and
personal best ones
that are front-wheel drive the last
thing you want to do particularly when
the weather's
a little bit on the wet or slippery side
is to go into a field
they hate going into fields they love a
hard standing
which is why primarily the car park
is so attractive to people so that is a
that is a benefit to them
and secondly we've got the toilet there
now i know they're not meant to empty
their
chemical toilets but a lot of people do
and a lot of people that are in the
camper vans do use the toilet block
rather than the one that's in there um
in the actual motorhome so we do we do
offer i think
two valuable um facilities there one is
the toilet the other is a hard standard
and i say 12 pounds a night they would
bite your hand off for 12 pound a night
i get sure so i would uh you know that
would be my recommendation
that we accept the two not two two uh
two nights camping
but it would be it would cost them 12
men a night you know because at the end
of the day
you know we can't be seen to be
in competition with with the local
caravan sites campsites
of which we've got too few but you know
if they're charging 15 pound and i and
we're only charging eight
you know that's undercutting it far too
much
they wouldn't stand a chance uh you know
if it's if it's that
so 12 ben and i is what i would suggest
thank you
okay next on my list is counselor lock
please
yeah i'd just like to come back to
counter forward i fully support that we
need to
control and just because i live in the
sticks i regularly
come to westwood oh and every door in
fact i was in the car park at avador
last saturday in september and i've
stopped and i counted 23 camper vans
then
and they were all parked along the front
and you couldn't see us of scabbing the
pavement or the sea
so that's definitely a move um that
should be made to that yellow
area and in fact this sadly i was in the
car park the fifth of december and there
was still
seven campervans there and i think three
would then depart from the
uh pavement um i agree with what the
council
say it should be a two-night stay
because the longer they stay the more
money they spend in the area um
so i think the zonal parking is an
excellent idea
it should be two nights and i will go
with councillor
do you say 10 pound caps of bushmeat at
night
12 pounds i will go with that as well
okay next on my list is counseling
hurley please thank you chair
yeah i mean i've listened to what
councilor brenton councillor bushby
said um yeah two nights i think it
should be
uh i don't go along with the zonal
parking the yellow
area i think camper vans may have a bit
of difficulty
parking there probably i do agree with
banning him from the
red area on the car park um i think
if it's 10 pounds per space then i'll be
20 pounds per night which would probably
be too high
on that basis i would probably go
anywhere between the 10 or the 12 pound
mark
i wouldn't be too too bothered one way
or the other because councillor bushby
has said if it's 15 pounds
in a campsite then maybe 12 is the area
we should be looking at
it's obviously very popular it's a great
initiative by torridge
and i'm sure the point made about how uh
camp
these campers want to go on to hard
standing is well made because nobody
wants to go onto soft ground and trying
to move on those vehicles away
afterwards
so i would go with two three and four
and say two nights and probably 12
pounds per night
thank you chair thank you mr hurley
i would go to councillor bright please
thank you chair i just want to check
that the change in charge will be
just an increase to the church fields um
rather than all of them oh that's okay
that because you know
one of them sacrificed torrington's
tourism as well
um yeah because i think all right
cancer can i just stop you there can you
just rewind quickly for me there because
somebody
spoke that i i didn't know what you said
you never said it again
i just wanted to check that the uh car
parking charge increase was only going
to be for the church fields car park and
not for
all of the ones across storage yeah
we're only discussing the notice of
motion which is a check through card
pack
well it doesn't say anywhere that it is
just that charge
change so i just want to make sure that
was key that's fine um
so my only concerns with the yellow site
is that um the council formed mentioned
campfires
so uh is there any liability to us if
like smoke from campfires or barbecues
across the road because it's quite close
i don't know about that
can i call an officer in there please
for uh sean would you like to answer
that now please cancel right
yes of course no we wouldn't permit that
activity and and
and certainly wouldn't want to take any
responsibility for anybody
breaking the rules on our car parks okay
okay so
it was still family with them not us
that's all i needed to make sure yeah
certainly it would be
you know within the rules of our car
parks we wouldn't accept people having
fires or barbecues
things like that that's not what we
permit okay all right that's it
um and uh the other thing
um is the yellow area big enough because
the red area looks like you get a load
of counterbalance in there but i'm not
sure if you get the same amount in that
yellow space
um but i agree that the yellow area or
somewhere near there that would be a
much better place for all campervans i
got
but is it big enough yeah can i just
come back on that
you can sure so so just for clarity the
yellow area would be the area that
counselor ford has proposed in his
notice of motion
for campervans the red area that's
indicated there
is an area that we're recommending we
should exclude campervan parking there
should be no
permissible campervan parking in the red
area in
in what is that proposal that part of
the proposal the rest of the car park
you'd be able to park camper vans in
okay all right so thank you
at this juncture um obviously casual
bright you've asked a few questions
there and council forward is one of the
opportune
counselors for it so character forward
your hand is up i will allow you to
speak
now and i will allow you to have your
last word as well
that's great and i appreciate that
because i would do the same thing for
anybody else taking the sticks or
whatever
basically it's like the report i think
was pretty good
and it's not about scoring points here
or having to go officers or fellow
counselors
this is something i feel strongly about
and that's actually come and i've got
i'm quite happy to provide evidence as
sean kearney asked me to
provide evidence let from stagecoach
which i julie did i don't make things up
it's not about that i'm here to
represent the people that's what i do
for my 98 pound a week and i'm
privileged to do so the thing is however
i've gone back to 2014 about small
businesses
none of those people on that panel live
in ecuador and they don't
think the fact what i will say is which
is not scoring points
i actually think ken james admittedly
who i totally admire with his integrity
admitted admitted the first time in
april was when i called him dough
i think the same with the head of pace
services and in sean kearney has not
exactly spent a lot of time in appledore
right i've not even thought about folks
where they've probably not spent a lot
of time in those worthy
all i want here is to get a resolution
we need tourism
desperately yes we do get a balance
not a problem and i will say that sean
kennedy i think
is actually suggestion about not having
a zoned area but having a no goal
area for camera vans it's far better
than what i propose i accept that
but counselors let's get real there's
been some there that's not even been
pain
at all also i must get this in no
i did mention to both ken and
head of pay services about flexible
working
we have actually advertised twice in the
last five months
for civil enforcement officers and then
they
they factor in about overtime now come
on the refuge collectors
whatever start at five or six in the
morning we could change
our contract employment for
new civil enforcement officers because
we gotta get real here
about being more efficient going forward
and with that i'll leave it and now come
in at the end
thank you guys i'm gonna go straight to
our chief executives uh mr hearst would
you like to respond to that as you have
mentioned
uh yes thanks chair and thanks
councillor ford um that's actually
something sean and i or sean cooney and
i have been discussing
uh this morning um in light of the the
report
something we need to to look at going
forward
because cancer falls quite right um
campervan's turn up after our ceos have
finished the evening and sometimes leave
before our charging starts in the
morning
so it's something we need to be more
proactive in managing so that's
something we plan to look at for next
year
thank you very much i will go to council
laws please
uh uh thank you chair i chat
if you can just give me a minute because
i want to just look at this
i support counsellor ford in many ways
but you have to look at this in two ways
campervans are going to be
vital for income
for our changing holiday market and we
should address this
i would like to trigger something i hope
in a bigger
picture if we looked at just this corner
of torridge where we have uh westwood
hoe and appledore
two totally different places very close
together appledore is truly
suffering uh you can go and see
campervans in the summer in private
private streets the whole place as we
know is chock-a-block
and it was fine not fine but
this is brought a whole thing of parking
to the fore what on earth they do
without church fields i do
don't know okay so we put the price up
on church fields and i can tell you
where they'll go
but go straight out onto the boroughs
because we don't have a parking order
out there
there's no fines applicable apart from
taking their name and address
they go out there just after tea time
they watch the sun down
go down they go to the local pubs they
disappear completely off the face of the
earth when we go to lock the pros
up the next not
field available ground you could put 50
or 60 camper vans on there
uh they would keep the income in the
area and they would love it because
they're close to shops restaurants pubs
because appledore is just it's
it's its own worst enemy it's so
successful
great we've got to find another
way of satisfying this market don't want
to drive them down to butte
we want to keep them here we want to
make them feel welcome
we're going to have to find another
place for them to park
thank you chair uh yeah i mean
10 12 12 12 pounds seems good to me
um maybe 15 is a little bit too far
but we're just going to drive them out
onto the boroughs can shawn answer
on on what his ideas or what we can do
to stop the the burrows run
thank you chair okay thank you very much
councillor laws um
mr kearney you have got your hand up
would you like to respond to that please
yes of course yeah um so we can
investigate
uh whether we could bring the boroughs
within the parking order to give us some
more enforcement powers i can't say
whether that's
uh possible or not yet tonight and and
you know i do
i do accept much of what council law
says about the concerns around sort of
displacement
um one thing we do have to point out is
there is a covenant on wilkie's field
car park that prohibits overnight states
so we couldn't accept uh accept that so
we can't we couldn't allow that
nice try okay we
have um council hicks please we'll be
next
uh thank you mr chairman these people
who've got camper vans i
i can think of two members of torres
councillor brenton admits it councillor
pennington's another and maybe others
they're not hard up um
like yesterday listening to the football
on five live
they were saying that the
gate fee for tottenham was 60 pounds
and one of the commentators said that's
cheap i paid more than that to park my
car overnight at islington
so i'm going with councillor ford on 15
pounds a night
it's right that you stop them parking in
the red area
they should be able to park anywhere but
we need the money
two nights fine but keep the price up
it's too
cheap well said
okay thank you much council hicks i
would go to councillor haines
you were on the list i'm not leaving you
to last on anything like that just going
for order thank
thank you yeah um just like to thank
sean for
meeting us as epidural counselors yeah
down on the site
um and thank you for um responding in
terms of removing the caravans from the
water side but i'm not happy
very happy about the solution proposed
of letting
campervans park on the left side
anywhere else in the car park
rather than in a zone because
members must be aware of how much
pressure there is
now on appledore um it's popular place
and it's a car park it's primarily a car
park not a campervan park
so in my view it should there should be
a limited
zone for camper vans otherwise you're
going to carry on with this
no bulls sorry
councillor james you're muted now sorry
sorry tom
which bit didn't you listen to shall i
start at the beginning or not
i'm not happy about not allocating a
zone
that's it sorry from there yet yeah
um because of the huge pressure on apple
door though i do take
council laws points that um
there is a crying lead for a proper
provision for caravans and camper vans
and
that's this is what we're looking at at
northern of trying to
look at the whole thing holistically and
finding
searching out an alternative site for
for cars to park and camper vans but if
you're going
if you just let campervans park on the
left side your
um councillor lock has already said she
counted 23 in the summer
you're gonna have campervans dominating
the car park and cars not being able to
find anything
um as to the charge i think at least 10
pounds would be correct
um thank you very much chair that's my
view
okay very much councillor haynes i would
go to councillor james
thank you chair and um just for
councillor ford thank you for
the warm words and it wasn't my first
time in april but we did have a very
good morning there because we looked at
the problem with the jet skis
and also where the checked area is where
the buses turn
somebody come and actually park there
while we were actually stood looking at
the site
so there is an issue with the people
parking in the checked area which is
needed for buses turning
we have discussed the car park
attendance um
being there more in uh time suited to
when the camper vans are going to be
there
and i fully support the redstone as
being
not for campervans i'm a little bit
unsure um
with the designated area because the
question is what happens if there's more
turn up
or if there's less and there's empty
spaces stood there
um and then cars won't park there
and also because campervans take up more
than
a normal car parking space uh
i don't know whether we've looked at the
exact area that they would take up
within the yellow zone
so i'm a bit nervous of actually
designating the zone
but i do accept the number turning up we
could end up with
only half the car park available for
cars um
certainly on the left-hand side anyway
and on the fee i think
12 pound or 15 but i certainly think it
should be 12.
thank you chair okay sean you've got
your hand
i'll go to you first please then
canceled bushby after please thank you
chad it's only certainly a really quick
point of clarification i just wanted
members to be aware that
um during normal so uh hours between 8
a.m and 6 p.m
if a camper van comes into the car park
they only pay the normal tariff the same
as a car
except if they're overhanging two bays
and then we'd expect them to buy two
tickets
and this is prime this is for overnight
stays
so when you get 27 i think councillor
i'm not sure whether that was during the
day she was talking about
or whether that was the overnight stay i
think it probably was during the day i
don't think we've had an incident where
we sold
26 or 27 overnight um
tariffs can confirm that that was four
o'clock in the afternoon right okay fine
so that's just a point of clarity chair
thank you very much council bushby
please
thank you sharon um just an observation
i
if you if you look at the red zone
you've got on the edge of the water's
edge you've got
roughly 15 cars there um clearly if you
had 23 motor motor homes there
you know the line would be far longer
than that it would probably stretch
all the way down over the slipway um so
clearly the
i think you'll find that there will be a
a natural thinning out of the numbers
when motorhome owners realize
that they cannot park on that river's
edge because
i've been down there lots of times i've
been down there attended the broken down
motor rooms that they left the lights on
all night they couldn't start it
on a few occasions and they love to park
long ways
along that water's edge because they've
got a wonderful view
you know they've got a panoramic window
in their motorhome and they're looking
at the jet skis and the boats they're
looking across to install
as soon as they realize they can't park
there any longer
and that they have to park within that
yellow zone
or whatever zone we say they have to
park overnight
i think you'll find the numbers will
diminish naturally
um that's just my observation and
you know if 15 pounds is what counselor
ford is
um uh you know really serious about and
council hicks is
also uh you know thinking about 15
pounds you know i'm all for
putting the charge up i mean i said 12
purely because
most of the caravan sites around here
charge around about 15 pounds a night so
if we made i don't see why we should be
making it
any cheaper than um a camper van site or
a motor home
or caravan park whatever you whatever
you call it you
not all of them offer a mains electric
hookup
but they still charge 15 pounds a 9 in
fact
they charge 18 pounds a night if you've
got a hookup
so 15 pounds if we're going to charge
that i'd go along and support anyone
that's going to propose that
thank you okay uh counselors before i
invite anyone else to speak um
just want to remind you all we have an
in-depth discussion here which is great
which should be doing
for transparency within um we have two
proposals that weren't seconded
okay and then we've had two ideas
bouncing around so we do really need to
get to the nitty-gritty now and
something to make a firm proposal then
some with the second a good proposal so
counselor ford i i will invite you to
get at this juncture to try and sway the
minds of
some of the members on the committee
please chair
sorry i i i've got to know that
councillor look
seconded councillor bushby's no
the word she said uh stacey the word
i've got written down was go along
that's not a second in or
in favor you know there's not words
we're going to be using let's go along
well i've got two two nights sorry chair
i've got two nights proposed by
councillor bushby at 12 pounds per night
and councillor locke agreed that but i
perhaps she could confirm if she
seconded or not
i stacy at the moment as i've got there
is nobody
there's proposals but there's no
seconders and to just say i go along
will i go along with a few things that
people said so far this evening but i
need it in clarification
so it's in writing so we can actually
make a firm proposal and secondary on it
please
so counselor forward i will bring you in
please
counsel the ford are you there you're
muted can you
right i'll keep this brief because i say
we've had a good debate i i i respect
that for more counsellors
um something i'll pick up very uh
quickly from sean
um he's on about he did use the word he
expects people
to pay or whatever we need to get better
with monitoring i don't want to dwell on
that but we do in
in whatever the overview of whatever we
do we need to get better
what i'll simply say is uh give me a
minute
there's no other car park intolerance on
the ship with the view that
churchfield's got and also it does
actually have
a bus tournament terminal and that's
what concerns me
whereby bus coming turn around i see
this regularly
then we'll deal with january the jet
skis we need more campsites
i am actually happy and i think sean's
uh
even i understand what councillor haines
was saying about
uh zone there is which i propose i did
say this short one i respect him he rung
me up a week or so ago just trying to
get to a sensible grown-up solution here
i think his proposal is easier to work
than mine about every zoned area and i
accept that
so what i'm simply saying is i'm quite
happy also
to go for two nights what i'm simply
saying is however
in a bigger scheme of things you can't
even get fish and chips on claws for
eight quid
you won't get two points for eight quid
i am not open iron man or roth
and i'm not just get the price right and
i'll go for two nights
i'll even with the caveat i said to sean
review it in 12 months and see what's
happened i don't think
the council will end up with a negative
if i think
it'll be break even i'm thinking i don't
know that
that is pie in the sky except but let's
reduce the numbers a little bit
we need tourism we need better campsites
and with that i'm going to leave it
okay mr hurst you've got your hand on
the right um please
uh yes thanks chair it's just to say
following up from what uh
uh stacy dory said i had council lockers
second in
uh councillor bushby's proposal as well
as well
tom uh recorded that so it might be
worth just
checking with councillor locke i i will
i will chat with council lock steve but
um
i am chairing the meeting and there was
no i want to get resolved unless courses
do but i want it done right
now counselor lock at the time did not
second it she said i can't really
second it now i i didn't i did second
did it i did say i would second
captain's proposal
no well because i i'm not trying to be
awkward here but
you didn't if you go back over it is
recorded so
thankfully go back for it you'll find it
you didn't do that so if you're happy to
second it
i'm happy to keep you in now his second
year counselor bush's proposal
and the proposal was the price was 12
pound a night
and it was over a two night period
maximum
okay so that you item to be
recommendation number two with a pricing
of 12. a night
and recommendation number three which
would be the two night stay
is that is that for clarification is
that clear for you yes it is
i'm not gonna second that do i want the
price to be 15 pounds
okay casual bushby yeah sure
are you happy to go with 15 pounds yeah
yeah i'll go to 50
modified to 15 pounds in support of
councillor ford's original motion
good point in that case i was second the
proposal then
check can i ask about the zoning yeah
it's only you can yeah
i'll clarify the zoning it's not clear
sean can we clarify this the zone in
there
is it zoned as it states not a zone so
so the the the things
if you're not invited to speak will you
please mute
it has become an instructive if it
counts as muttering underneath the
breath
when an officer is trying to speak so
can you just meet when you're not
talking police thank you counselor
counselor now sean over to you yeah
thank you chair
so so in the picture you've got the the
yellow
area was to depict the area that
councillor ford had suggested in his
notice of motion
should be set aside for campervan
parking and the red
box is where we're suggesting camper
vans shouldn't be allowed to park
now if you went with the exclusion in
the red
basically the rest of the car park would
be accessible for campervan overnight
parking
okay council laws does answer your
question
council laws you're muted yes chair and
i think that's the best of both worlds
because you're
you're not discouraging them but you're
excluding them from the view
you know from that area wow okay
councillor ford i did i i did offer you
your last word
i'm a man of my word so you love your
last word and i would have a proposal in
a second and i would go for a vote
counselor ford yeah thanks chair um yeah
again i think we can come to a
resolution there we
we know we all need tourism um but what
i'll say is it is unique car park
because i got photographs where it's
rampant and i've got a photograph of
bank and where it's empty
this is purely about churchfield yeah i
don't know why i do try to my best to
sometimes discourage people
from coming from ecuador to rapidly but
i'm not obviously not doing my job well
enough
it's very popular let's enjoy it welcome
people
and get a balance and both be civil to
the holiday maker
they pay good money to come down here i
wish them to come down here we need it
just be civil get sensible resolution
thank you chair
okay thank you mr ford uh miss story can
i go to you please just for
clarification that we get this proposal
right
it's been proposed and seconded okay yes
chad so it's proposed
by councillor bushby that this day be
two nights
with uh and the second part of that was
15 pounds per night
and that amendment has been agreed by
councillor locke so it's been seconded
as well
okay councillors i think we've had a
great debate on this i'm going to go
to the vote we've had a proposal
what about what about uh recommendation
number four
are we going to authorize the officers
to seek amendments
in case in case people do decide to go
the northern boroughs
sean would you just like to clarify that
for me please
so chair yes i mean it would be helpful
if if um
the proposal would just add number four
a recommendation for
to their proposal because that just
basically gives us the
tools by which we can enforce the
exclusion zone
how could you do that guys the bush be
happy with that yes very happy okay
are you not taking any more debate
no thank you council brenton i'm going
to go to the vote now please yeah i'm
happy with that chair i'm happy with it
yeah we still have another clarification
on the on
on the proposal it's not including
clearly what sean
said about excluding the red area from
the camping town
i think it was it was cancer laws
is it now included stacy
it wasn't in what place he said let
let's california so council bush b is
happy to amend to add that into the
into the proposal perhaps cancer luck
could confirm that she's happy for that
to be in the exclusion zone as well
with signage with signage to actually
indicate to
campervan owners that that is prohibited
i'm happy to second that good okay
councillor
yes thank you okay councillors that's
all fair to everybody
stacy would like to come back yes chad's
just gonna say would you like me just to
clarify just so that members know what
they're vote voting on
so it's um a two night stay
up to a maximum of two night stay 50
pounds per night
15 pounds per night and the red zone in
the picture
is to be excluded for campervan parking
yeah okay to the parking order
an amendment to the parking order thank
you councillor hicks
okay lovely thank you much counsellors
you've got a firm proposal there it's
clarified by
our solicitor i would go to the vote
there please
thank you chair councillor brenton
against you'll force him onto the street
so
park in the streets i've seen it all
before carry on
councillor hicks for
cancer hurley or councillor james
or councillor laws or
councillor locke or councillor mcgough
for councillor wiseman
he's no talking he doesn't take point
okay thank you
so that's ten four and one against chair
okay thank you very much thank you
councillors there's a good debate
i'll move on to item number ten all
right
to the community grant scheme on pages
22-24 we will receive the report from
the heady communities and place please
counselors can i please remind you again
to meet your microphones when you're not
to speak
thank you please meet people
yes sure i'm just working my way through
the list yeah
thank you very much thank you chair so
hopefully this is a fairly
straightforward report that in a normal
year
each counselor has a council of
community grants allowance of two
thousand pounds per canceler
to support projects in the ward and uh
the uh
eligibility criteria for those who set
out in the report
this year when covid uh the crisis
struck
the decision was made to take a thousand
pounds from each councillor
and form a pool of funding with some
other funds from other places
to distribute to uh parish and town
councils
to form part of their covid response
um when we were evaluating the
effectiveness of that basically what uh
we came to was that many of the towns
and parish councils hadn't actually
spent that money
so we've recouped it and the suggestion
is that we reallocate
a thousand pounds per councillor but
with a slight amendment to the
eligibility criteria
to enable you to be able to make
donations to charities
that are making a community covered
response because you would have been
excluded from doing that
under the original eligibility criteria
thanks jeff
okay thank you very much uh counselors
i've been to the floor
anybody like to speak please cancer
bushby your hand up straight away
i'd like to propose that we accept um
sean's um suggestion with the
get the money reinstated to councils
thank you okay
um you guys push me i'd like to second
that proposal
sean would you like to come back to that
yeah really quickly i should have
mentioned
that um councillor cottle honking as
lead member
um wasn't able to provide a response in
the report but she did indicate her lead
member support for this
in a telephone call i had with her in
the week okay lovely thank you
any other counselors wishing to speak i
can't see any hands up
okay i can mate counsel to bright please
thank you chair um just want to check is
the thousand pounds that we're getting
back
is that limited to just covered related
criteria or is it that it can be used
for everything and the code related
okay that's cool thank you very much
sean would you like to clarify
no it's not limited to covid you could
use it for normal community projects as
you would have done in a normal year
okay council leather good evening
evening chair thanks for letting me
speak just a six
sixth bullet point down activities which
the authority has no legal powers to
fund that needs a bit of explanation
because
northern town council has a general
powers of competence we can give
money to whoever we want and i don't
know what the position is
with the district council but that's not
very clear there
uh activities which the authority has no
legal powers to fund
i mean can we not grant you anything
provided it's not an illegal activity
okay thank you uh council leather uh
steve would you like respond or stacy
would you like to respond to
cancer level on that one please
you know i think it's always lovely that
we don't have a legal duty to respond
rightly said um you as councillors can
use your grants for whatever means um
you would like to
or whatever organization you'd like to
provide assistance to as long as it's
not unlawful
okay council leather is that is that
good enough that bullet point can be
removed because it doesn't mean anything
really
it doesn't mean anything
okay council love it have you finished
yeah just
yeah just because it's not something
that the authority
funds doesn't mean that we can't grant
to it as stacy said
so activities which the authority has no
legal powers to fund
that's nothing to do with what we as
councillors might want to give our
ground to
as as i said prabhan is not illegal
okay counselor dart i've got your hand
up please
yeah thanks chair just for clarity is
this going to kick in this
current year
we're talking about an immediate
reinstatement brilliant thank you
okay council laws please
clarification i always thought that we
couldn't support
churches
they can they can
right and yes chair i can respond to
that so what we've
allowed in the past is um you can
support a church
but you can't support the promotion of
their faith
so sometimes churches are the applicant
organization for a community project
that isn't necessarily about
the promotion of christianity or islam
or something like that
thank you council butchery please
thank you sure i was just going to point
out that um you know grants are not
available to an individual but actually
says that on the
on the sheet okay thank you very much
uh councillors we do have a proposal and
we do a proposal sorry in a second
so i'm going to move to the vote please
thank you chair councillor brenton or
councillor bright or councillor bushby
or councillor christie
councillor dart
paul councillor hicks
or councillor hurley or
councillor james or councillor laws
or counselor lock law
councillor mcgough for councillor
wiseman
that's unanimous chair okay lovely thank
you very much
okay let's move on to item number 11.
the decision taken
under urgency procedure pages 25 to 37
and the report will be delivered again
by the head of your communities and
places this time the first one was
placed but your places no
business night for you mr kearney over
to you yeah
a growing empire obviously chairman um
no it's uh this is a really
straightforward one
is this is this urgent council it's just
to declare an interest that i have
my business has actually received um
some grant fund
[Music]
lovely thank you much councillor dot
sean sorry about that
that's all right chair thank you very
much um yeah it's really straightforward
i won't i won't
go through the policy it's simply for
you to you can read through
it's for you to note the grant scheme
that we launched and
have been supporting communities with
thank you
okay uh stacy as it's obviously note
do we still need for public transparency
to
devotees
no chair you you don't it's it's been
agreed under the urgency procedure
but the constitution says that any items
that we agree under urgency has to be
reported at the next cnr so we're simply
reporting it chair
okay would any accountants would like to
speak on this before i move on to the
next item
okay that's a note thank you i move on
to item number 12
that set and decide monies to support
the capital programme this would be a
good one
pages 38 to 40 to receive the port of
the finance
manager and section 151 officer
thank you chair um
the 10th of november i presented um to
internal overview and scrutiny that the
council is looking at projected surplus
for the current financial year of 642
000 pounds at the report to internal
overscreen went into some detail
essentially and the detail is listed in
the report there
just over five hundred thousand pounds
of those projected surplus actually
relates to covid
19 related matters and put simply
the support that we've received from
central government has exceeded our
expenditure on covered related matters
and projected income
losses from co-forwarded matters and 140
000 pounds of
surplus are rolled from surplus to and
parenthesis with the right generally
throughout the year
so it's a very simple proposal
the proposal uh from internal over
scrutiny for saying our to
approve was that the council sets aside
the projected surplus of 642
000 pounds to support our capital
program which is actually the next item
on the agenda
which has a gap funding gap of circa 5
million pounds and there's a report
uh presentation that will do after this
item which i'll go through with members
as to how we've got such a gap on our
capital program
and possible options relating to that so
put simply
there's some members to agree with
internal overview and scrutinize and
recommendation at the surplus of 642 000
pounds is set aside for our capital
programme and the funding shortfall
happy to take any questions thank you
much
counselors over to you anybody got any
questions please
well i've got a i've got an issue with
something that's actually
on um the next page
and i don't know whether to voice it now
or
when we get to that page but are we
going to take a vote on this first
yes we yep
the northern borough center
are we still committing torah city
council
funding towards it or is it all grant
money that we've
got mr hayes could you come activities
yeah and minimal contribution from the
council we originally were going to put
on i think in the region of one million
pounds
into the um borough center and that's
been reduced because of the
scaled down the buddha center and also
getting
extra external funding i realize that
but what are we putting in
from ourselves
i'd have to just can you just give us
one second please yeah no no problem
oh dear
cancer is just again just to remind you
someone said oh dear can you just mute
yourself please and have that little
word in your
in your own head thank you
it'd be in the region of half a million
pounds that the council's own resources
are going into the borough centre
okay thank you okay
council hicks
properly proposed and seconded please
i'll propose if it hasn't been
i'll second it okay you've got proposal
by cousin hicks seconded by councillor
brenton
cashida james you're our leader i'll let
you speak
sorry i was just gonna second motion
that was all
okay no problem talk counselor lock
your last one before we go yeah can i
just ask and david on page 39
put it point 2.4
where he talks about future front
funding bit of an unfair question really
if he had a crystal ball does he think
the government will give us more funding
in 2122 the government has actually
already announced some covered funding
for
21 22 and it's 1.5 billion at a national
level
and they've not given us the not
clarified what our share
of that funding would be so i wouldn't
like to commit i have a
a rough idea because they said it may be
based on a similar basis to the transfer
of the covered funding but that hasn't
been
confirmed but nationally 1.5 million has
been earmarked
for covered funding in 2021 to 22
and the government has also announced
that he will extend the compensation for
the lost fees and charges until
i think the end of june a the first
three months
of 2021 22.
thank you very much thank you very much
mr hayes
so we've got a proposal from councillor
james to set the recommendation
a seconder from councillor brenton and
that's on page 40 recommendation
i'll move to the vote please
thank you chair councillor brenton
four thank you councillor bright
or councillor bushby again
councillor christie councillor dart
or councillor hicks or
councillor hurley or
councillor james or councillor laws
or councillor locke
or councillor mcguff
four and councillor wiseman
thank you so that's eleven four and one
against chair
lovely thank you very much okay i'll
move on to item number 13 the capture
program
update with the new pits pages 41-51
and to receive the report again from the
finance manager and
section 151 officer mr hayes over to you
again please
thank you chair what i want to do is
it's got a short presentation of eight
slides which
summarises the main points within the uh
report
firstly really the main point is i want
to explain to members the challenges
faced by torres district council and
actually funding its capital programme
outlined some of the new project
initiation documents are paid to as we
call new capital programme
and refer to the capital maintenance
issues we have on our existing property
portfolio and how we should manage them
on a financially
and also give members some insight into
the funding short for the council faces
arising from various things and i'll
detail that later on in the presentation
okay next slide please tom
okay this is just a recap we started
this financial year
with an approved capital programme of 23
million pounds that's at the top
and then berserker agreed that we should
make the submission
for future high street money that added
another 9.6 million pounds to our
capital program given an approved
program
of 32.7 million we identified funding
of 31.7 million given a gap of a million
however on the gap of a million the
devil is very much in the detail
grab the next slide please tom
okay so we've got an approved capital
program for 32.7 of nearly 33 million
in the bank is 7.6 mil 7.7 million
pounds that's actually now reserved
we've already set aside that money so
that gives us a shortfall of 25 million
then we're forecasting additional
funding of revenue contributions
new home bonus capital receipts and
capital grants
needs to be emphasized that the future
sources of finance
are not guaranteed the revenue
contributions we've got set aside
guaranteeing that we've already budgeted
to set our money for example to replace
our refuse fleet
and within the say for example the
future high street
bid there was some capital receipts and
some central government grants
new homes boldness however is um
additional source of capital funding to
the council well that's been severely
impacted by central government changes
2021-22 will be the last year of its
operation
i mean at its peak the council received
two million pounds in new homes bonus
of which one million was earmarked for
capital that is no longer the case
so after the forecast of future
contributions that we'll make over the
life of the capital programme we've got
a funding shot for
of 8.4 million and we've got approved
borrowing
of 7.4 million that approved borrowing
members will recall will be for the
environmental center some homelessness
provision and within the future high
street bid
there was some approved um borrowing so
that's where we've got the shortfall of
one million pounds
however you know what i'd want members
to do when they're looking at this slide
in front of
them see us future funding for 16.6
million
that's not entirely guaranteed that's
the forecast so that's what i want
members to
focus on could i have the next slide
please tom
[Applause]
oh sorry one second
okay so our
the world doesn't stand still so
obviously new capital programmes and
pigs come along
all the time our estates manager adrian
redwood has identified that we really
need to make you most
long-term plans for future capital
programme in terms of a rolling program
of work so for example here
he's saying we should build a gear
marking 410 000 pounds every year
towards capital works such as punching
the car parts you know resurfacing
general capital improvements of 150 000
and 180 000 pounds a year
from to support our leisure which is
about 60 000 pounds per facility
and he's proposing in the next year
capital work and capital projects to be
funded from this money that we're going
to set aside from our revenue budgets
river house phase two greenhouse wind
rolling refurbishment deterrent pool
roof which is already started
some paths that cuts down and then some
works on bridge street bridge buildings
if that's
not sold there's also some other um
capital projects that's agent identified
which is planning to
fund from the planned maintenance
reserve just so every members are aware
the planned maintenance service set up
money was set aside from services in
previous years so that's
money we've got in the bank so next
slide
however our agencies identify some of
the significant
capital projects that we may require
uh which don't necessarily come with any
funding so he says the units at
industrial units at tamar lane really
should be demolished and rebuilt however
we'd only really proceed with that if
they were self-financing
so there's various new um capital
projects he's identified and they're
listed there
such as the renewing the plant and
machinery at the fish stock
we're aware obviously there's a backlog
of maintenance issues arising at 1610 at
the
leisure filters still to determine what
our responsibility what 1610's
responsibility is but they're not for
650 000.
and we've got increased default costs
since that was last approved
of 1.3 million and that includes some
additional
costs relating to a new road at one of
the sites and also some land which we
may acquire at the
environmental site which could be used
for future development
we're all sat in the town hall now and
the roof at some point needs a
replenishing
and there's some significant costs there
are three quarters of a million
and also set aside some money for ground
maintenance equipment
for when the service if the service
comes in house and we're responsible for
providing the equipment
and the linear defenses at westwood hall
where we
estimate at some point between now and
2024 25 we may actually incur costs of
up to
three million pounds um and we hope we'd
expect um
our contribution to be match funded by
the environmental agent so
our contribution to be net 1.5 million
i'll come on to that
in a slide in a bit so you see at the
bottom there there's a total value of
new capital projects
is 9 million pounds 9.4 million 2
million which relates to ongoing
maintenance
can open that slide please tom
okay so where does that leave us so we
started off at the top
with an approved capital program after
the future high street of 32.7 million
with funding
at 31.7 million give us a gap of a
million
obviously this alluded to earlier within
that feud that funding of 31.7 million
a significant proportion that is
actually projected
funding it's not funding that is
guaranteed
adrian identified that we needed to set
money aside for a rolling program
and over the period of the medium-term
financial strategy going up to 2025-26
that's 2 million and 50
000 pounds and we'd set aside that by
making a contribution from our revenue
budgets and i'll come to that later
that is a pressure on our revenue budget
we've got some new projects which we'd
fund from the planned maintenance
reserve
we have the money already set aside in
the planned maintenance reserve
so that's funded and then you've got one
of these um the tamar lane
scheme of a million pounds which is a
demolishing rebuild we said we'd only
proceed with that if that was
self-financing
so the other capital projects amounted
to six million
of which we'd expect a contribution of
1.5 million
from the environmental agency for the
linear defenses at westwood hall so that
leaves us a gap
of 4.6 million at 4.6 million to the one
million that was previously identified
that's where we got a funding shortfall
of 5.6 million grab the next slide
please tom
can you just go back a slide please
though
um i just want to make a point at this
juncture just for reference
we've got a capital project there for a
programme of 42 million pounds
the net revenue budget of tourist
district council is 10 million pounds a
year
in a normal year our growth spends
excluding housing benefits is 16 million
pounds
so the scale of our capital program is
exceptionally large given the scale of
our revenue budgets
thank you tom can just move on
okay so how can we close the gap
we've alluded to that we're making less
of a contribution to the borough centre
so we believe we can claw back 500 000
pounds
from the original budget for the
council's contributions to the border
centre we have a strategic property
acquisition reserve which currently has
a balance of 700
000 pounds so we could freeze
all new strategic property acquisitions
and
however if we did that we'd have no
money available to develop
some of the profit the land that we
already have such as the land at term
halls with reactive business hatchimal
in torrington middle dock ecuador
and cast down phase three we've got
cleave wood capital receipts that we're
expecting of just under 1.3 million
and tad worthy a capital receipt of 600
thousand tabworthy i believe is in the
westwood area
and we have a hopefully a capital
receipt on our way for bridge buildings
we've recently received a hundred
thousand pounds for westwood hole
park i'm looking for confirmation from
colleagues yes thank you
and members of just this minute approved
a contribution from our 2021 surplus of
642 000 pounds
so there's kind of an option one and an
option two
assuming all those things in option one
the gap falls to 1.4 million
assume not making an assumption about
the capital receipts for cleave wood and
tadworthy
and bridge building which of course are
uncertain that gives us a gap of 3.7
million
okay the only way really realistically
we'd be able to close that gap
would be to borrow the money if we
borrow the money the obviously
following isn't a free it does come with
costs both in terms of the interest and
the repayment of the principal
so in the i'm color blind so if members
please forgive me in the wildcard orange
which says annual revenue costs
that's the annual cost of borrowing the
money to bridge the gap on the capital
program so we were to borrow 1.464
million that'd be 117 000 pounds per
year
it was to borrow 3.679 million that'd be
294 000 pounds
just at the very bottom of the screen
you'll see for comparison increasing car
park traffic to car parking charged by
10 will generate additional revenue of
130 000 pounds
20 would generate additional income of
260
000 pounds so i have the next slide
please tom
so to summarize
we've got a current capital program
after the future house rate of 30 just
under 33 million
we've identified new pips new capital
projects of 9.4 million gives us a
capital program of 42 million
we've got a fund funding shortfall of
5.6 million and depending on those
option one or option two
we've got a gap of 1.4 or 3.7 million
the annual revenue impact of the new
pit and the sort of the car parks and
the leisure for example is 410 000
pounds
and the revenue impact of the borrowing
to bridge the gap
varies between 117 and 294 000
given an impact on our revenue for
funding the capital programme
on a best-case scenario of just over
half a million which is 527
on a more likely scenario 704 thousand i
think
repeat again this needs to be compared
against a net
revenue budget of just over 10 million
pounds so the capital
programme is an exceptionally big
burden for this council to fund it's an
amazing challenge we have
in front of us just at the bottom there
are some revenue generation options
raising car parking charges by 20 200
would raise 260 000 pound a year
and raising the charge for green waste
from 35 to 50 pounds would raise another
180 000 which would raise
440 000 pounds so just before we move on
to next slide i know i don't want to
sound like a record stuck in a groove
what i'm trying to say to members is
that we've got a capital program that's
been approved we want to fund
it is not half a million to three
quarters of a million
to fund it from our revenue and that
is against a net revenue budget 10
million pounds so
as you can see that's a very you know
that's five to seven and a half percent
of our net revenue budget the pressure
is just from our capital program move on
to that slide please tom
so what are our other options well we
could simplify the environmental sensor
and that would generate significant
savings i i we don't have the figures to
handle would not be well in excess of a
million pounds if we just went for
essentially a refuge depot rather than
an environmental sensor
of course we could sell tdc assets to
generate future
additional capital receipts our
alternative the only option we do have
then is a reduction of discretionary
revenue expenditure
i'm happy to take any questions
thank you very much for that councillors
over to you
councillor christie your first on peace
thank you yes uh
sobering um can i ask a couple of
questions because
um the page that was misprinted that we
had to run off ourselves
this was page 51 appendix one
and can i just ask a few questions about
some of the so-called high priority
ones these are the ones in red
um can i ask what westwood ho
linear defense is separate but there's
157
000 pounds so northern burrows estuary
works
can you tell me what they are
okay equipment offers that's my first
question
okay we're doing one at a time okay so
can someone answer that one
please i'm
not entirely certain we haven't got all
the pigs in front of us that something
has been approved some years ago so
uh chair will uh have a look the detail
behind that
and share the share the project with
members of the committee
okay so christy are you happy with that
first question i'm just intrigued what
it is but there we are
um there's two other things on there
which
um i'm slightly puzzled about torridge
bowling club wall
46 000 the first i've ever heard of that
and yet apparently it's a high priority
and the other one is um torrent of
market refurbishment
45 000 pounds yet you look on the other
list and it's got a question mark beside
it has that been decided or not or what
i responded yep so these these are
projects are already been approved in
previous years
um the bit that's got a question mark on
the earlier slide
was counselor in relation to counselor
bright's notice of motion which came to
uh full council um a meeting or so ago
so this
that would the question mark in addition
to this works here
in terms of the bowling club ball again
that's been in the capital program for a
number of years
and it's a responsibility torridge has
to to rebuild up more
um well thank you this news to me i
can't remember
hearing about those can i ask one other
uh very contentious question
the biggest sum here is three million
quid for
westwood ho linear defense
and i was told and you told us that uh
we mainly be paying half that because
the environment agency will match the
funding
do we actually need to look again at
this because it seems an awful lot of
money
to try and keep the sea out when really
you know you're never going to do it so
are we actually going to spend that
money
on all that defense on just that one
part because i'm afraid we're going to
have to look very seriously at that
steve could you respond to that please
um that will be something for
members to debate and decide upon um
obviously these are early estimates from
adrian agents
as members will know uh working with the
environment
agency and other part parties to look at
the linear defenses
down at westwood hill so you know that
will be something
um and if members want to look at other
options and or not doing something
that's
what for members to consider in a bit
more detail
at a later date
okay counselor christy any more
questions it says no
counsellor laws please
chris dude i have to move pretty damn
quickly because it's happening now
the lorries are arriving with the huge
boulders
it is it is vital work there's 72 homes
at risk here
and it's one of those horrible things
that happens
when you've got a district council
facing the atlantic i'm afraid
thank you okay councillor bushby please
thank you chair um a couple of points
that i'd like to make
councillor christie touched on one you
know the the
significant sum for the linear defenses
clearly you know we're not talking just
about the
area near the um slipway and we're
talking about the pebble ridge in
general here
the linear defenses you know three
million pound is
a significant sum but if you look at the
all of the reports that have been done
by various specialist
companies over the years that the one
that springs to mind is the black of
each report which
says in there that there will have to be
a hard engineering solution
found to defend um northern boroughs
from uh
you know from inundation and clearly
that's what we're talking about
a hard engineering solution so yes i'm
not surprised it's gonna cost
you know several million uh the longer
they leave it the more it costs
but with that in mind why are we still
persisting with even spending
half a million of our council's money
on northern borough centre when as
councillor
if we take what country chris he said
literally
you know the verse isn't going to be
there the pebble ridge will be there
so clearly why would you you know it's
fully to actually commit to
to this you know this this new visitor
center and
what they've got there now may not be
brilliant but
it's suffice it suffices what they need
for
for now it's it does the job so that's
one point that i'd like to make i'd also
like to
to talk about the the um on your
environmental depot
whether you call it an environmental
depo or you scale it down i'm not too
fast but what we
desperately need clearly is a new depo
for all of our refuse bins all of our
other vehicles
a new maintenance workshop i went down
the last
last week to offer my
assistance because richard was in the
workshop on his own
you know probably the only one of our
managers that actually gets his hands
dirty
um but click there he was in the
workshop with his overalls on and fair
play to the guy for doing what he did
absolutely brilliant but with my
background i did make the offer
if you wanted me to i'd want to give
them a hand um
but nevertheless the you know the
the center the the new environmental
depot presumably you know we've got an
identified site haven't we
anyone steve sorry councillor bushby i
didn't catch the the very end of what
you said
we must have now got an identified site
for the new depot
uh chair that's that's what we're
currently working on and we'll be
bringing a report to
to members uh shortly well the reason
they asked the question
i'm i'm trying to get my head around you
know the actual cost involved in
providing something like that
well if we can save 1.3 million pounds
by having not such a grandiose
um you know recycling depot then clearly
you know that
needs to be um you know needs to be
looked at seriously i mean the the the
actual cost of the land i mean i know
one of the costs of the lands that
that's how it's turned down um but that
leaves
a huge amount of money to to actually
build a depot
you know these things don't cost that
much nowadays once you've actually got
the site
you can put up fantastic commercial
buildings go up and look at what peter
hawking is doing up at deputy
pine that type of building um you know
it doesn't need to be all singing all
day we don't want to build a riverbank
house to repair
vehicles in that's what i'm saying it's
a it's a commercial
steel frame building type of structure
and i'd like to be involved in that at
some point when you do actually sit
around the table
and think about that but um clearly yes
if we can if we can save money by doing
that i'd be all in favor of that
in fact i would have thought we could
save a lot more than the 1.3 million
and with savings on that and getting rid
of that
monstrosity on the borough center and
saving another 500
000 i think would be the way to go so
two and a half million pounds i think
could be saved quite easily
thank you chair okay counselors before i
go any further counselor but i will take
it
as tongue-in-cheek obviously the common
debate the only officer gets hands dirty
um obviously every officer's different
job different trades etc so you know
i did see some of ray smiles there did i
i'm talking real dirt on the hands not
ink
i'm just i'm just clarifying before it
gets spun out of context kind of push me
i just
want to make sure we get it right now if
anyone goes to standards i don't want
that happening to anybody
thank you first down for everything yeah
uh counselor
sorry because have you finished now
sorry i finished thank you
thank you chair thank you much uh
councillor haynes please
yeah sorry about that thanks thanks
chair um
yeah just a few comments first um i
agree with councillor bushby that the
borough center should be a candidate for
consideration that we don't
go ahead with it um bearing in mind the
sea level rise consideration um also
i wonder you know some of the projects
could be subject to grant funding that
we've that have been listed for us
which would reduce our commitment and
also
i suggest that we it's long overdue to
put parking charges up and other charges
to contribute extra income having said
that um
i'm very concerned as lead member for
climate that
there doesn't seem to be any budget
allocation
for climate projects the reason why
i think is because any projects would
have to come out of the carbon plan
and the carbon plan is about nine to ten
it's going to be about nine to ten
months
late by the time it's produced i'm i
just query whether the opportunity to
put forward projects and get funding
so bearing in mind we've committed to a
climate emergency
um could i get some sort of
statement of the consideration of the
situation from
maybe david hayes or steve hurst please
through youtube
i would go for mr harris please would
you like to respond to it
uh uh yes thanks cheers a couple of
points
um obviously council bushby made some
points about the environment center if i
deal with those first
um then what we'd be proposing to do
david hayes is working with his finance
team and with
richard and be engaging with council
leather as a
lead member looking at refreshing the
report that
members saw back in 2017
when members first approved the
the development of environment center so
that report's been updated
and that will be reported back to
members in the new year
obviously this is just um alerting
members to some of those things
um in relation to councillor haims his
comments he made two points
uh one about um if we get external
grants then that will reduce the gap
well as david hayes pointed out earlier
ex
forecast external grants are already
included
in the the modeling he's done um so
it'll only change
if there's more grants than uh than are
already forecast
in here um in terms of funding for
uh climate emergency well at present as
you said
the carbon pollen is in development i
understand
janet is well advanced in preparing that
and i think it's due
uh to go to internal over and scrutiny
so until we've got some
detailed projects coming forward for
that
then obviously we can't put anything in
and
so they may they may not all be capital
projects so it may be a mixture of
revenue
and capital projects so the timetable
for
this is um going forward
for the capital programme to be approved
in february at full count full council
meeting in february so
there is still a little time if other
things come forward but as david's
already alluded to and pointed out
your capital program is already over
committed so anything more you add in
you'll either have to take something out
or manage
the the budget in such a way as to be
able to fund that
yeah can i come back just briefly yes
you can continue yep
yeah can we just get can i have
confirmation that there is actually
still an existing budget for climate
there was one
or ten thousand pounds but i gather
that's been eroded by about
nearly 2 000 already on something um
can you do
left at the end of the year off next
year with eight thousand then put
another ten thousand away
thank you chad okay um
councillor bushby i will let you come
back because steve first answered a
couple of
questions that you raised earlier for i
interjected
you chair um would it be possible to
have a copy of that 2017 report
um for the environmental center please
uh okay if i come back yep that's not a
problem that's not a problem at all
it was a an open cap full council
meeting i think it was january
2017 but um i'll ask uh the democratic
services
circulate that report but a hardcore
problem and secondly share um
i i want to make a proposition um that
we delete
the northern borough center from the
capital program
okay uh you've made a proposal you
delete the
borrower center from the program and as
a member
sorry steve go up so i was just going to
ask if sean can come back
on that because there's we're quite well
advanced on that project
so if that's okay okay let's have an
update
sean yes of course yeah and so at a
recent meeting
of uh cnl we we went through the changes
to the borough center
and actually we're giving the clear
instruction from the committee to
progress
and on that basis adrian's been busy
letting contracts for its delivery so
before you make the decision we probably
should
understand where we are financially with
that because we might well be
financially committed to quite some
extent on that
do we have any figures at the moment
sean are we money in on money at the
moment
uh we we've been granted 1.2 million
pounds from the coast communities fund
year
we've been given an additional 400 000
pounds uh
from the getting building fund which has
just been confirmed this week
and then obviously we were making a
contribution from our account capital
programme
we brought a report basically saying
that we were looking at a modular
construction and as part of that we
agreed to a contract where we paid up
front for the construction of the
modular
units so i'm not sure where we are in
terms of having paid up front for some
of that building
so i think it would be perhaps um
a little premature for us to be
excluding that because i don't know we
can report the consequences to you
tonight
okay um at this moment i'm going to
bring in council hicks at the moment
council hicks thank you mr chairman
i think what you need to do is to bear
this document
in mind when you're making future
decisions
we have to be extremely careful here
uh it's all very wonderful members
coming forward with proposals that this
be done that be done wouldn't it be
great if we could have this and that
i'm thinking particularly of the three
yellow items
marked on one of the pages the turret
and market
the play provision
it's all lovely sky in this
pie in the sky stuff if you're not
careful
because it's got to be paid for and
who's it paid for
the way this budget is produced it's
telling you
that eventually it's got to be paid over
the council tax and we shall have it be
having to put it up
to pay for what are in many respects
glory items for members of a community
because i read in the torrent crier how
the members are proposing and getting it
moving
things are going to happen in torrington
well we're all paying for it
not one penny of this capital
expenditure goes to anything in my ward
so why should my constituency be paying
for other people's glory
just members need to bear in mind
it isn't a monkey puzzle tree which just
keeps producing
we've got to be very careful with our
money and one of the frightening things
i read is
sale of td assets to generate capital
receipts
one of the assets you've got that would
sell are some of your
light industrial developments at cast
down that torrent
that um holds the
and yet they all produce rent which
keeps your council tax
down and you know these people are going
to spend money they're going
to do this they're going to do that and
then they'll come the next election and
say oh they've done their
utmost to keep council tax down it's
rubbish
council brenton
hey chair i was gonna ask david about
the interest rates on
on borrowing is this uh three percent um
is that the very best rate we can do um
bearing in mind
you know we're we're part of the um
association of district councils i'm
sure
sure we carry a huge clout i mean three
percent it's not bad if you were
uh lending money to somebody that that
sort of rate certainly more than any
individual get from their
bank yeah the quote the rates were
quoting actually the public works loan
board rates
actually since that report was done i
think they actually reduced the rates
and there's a have yet to
be around to it some councils borrowed
lots of money from the public works loan
boards to fund
investments in property portfolios
outside of their area
to generate a return and then the
government
increased the borrowing rate with the
bwlb
to deter that kind of um activity
so when this report was written there
was the interest rates that were
applicable at that time they've actually
come down somewhat
since the report was actually written
like literally in the last week
but yes the as a public works loan board
rates is the rates that we would use
that's where we'd borrow our money and
generally that is the most efficient way
a council can borrow money thank you
david thank you
okay council branson thank you okay um
before i go to another member
um on page 50 on the recommendations to
take the full council
a number two recommend a full council of
the next steps on the notices of motion
in the context of a capital funding
shortfall could somebody please explain
to me
what that means in layman's terms please
don't jump at once
refer back to page 46
of the report
uh you'll notice there's the three
record uh three notices
or two no this emotion if i come forward
uh that have yet to be properly costed
up
so i think the recommendation is to
consider do you still
wish work to be done uh
bringing those proposals forward bearing
in mind the capital program
is already overspent this is a question
to sorry questions and committee members
on that okay obviously on my my side of
things there uh mr hurst
obviously we've had no reports actually
done on these notices of motion at a
moment at all so we don't have any
costings whatsoever
and they were put back some time ago and
they've been brought back i think twice
some of them have
by myself as well you know but i i do
remain neutral in the chair so i'm not
going to debate this anymore for myself
i'm going to move on to councillor
bushby's got his hand up
counselor lock you did have your hand up
but it's gone
thank you chair uh well i think
coachella hicks is hitting now
on the head um we certainly do need to
be
very careful you know what what we're
spending here because it's you know it's
easy to spend other people's money um
but i think our section 151 officer
david hayes tried to
put tried to put a bit of a steer away
because he mentioned it
at least two i think three times um
which i think there was a there was a
sort of a there was a message that he
was trying to convey there
in as much as it could
it could be argued that our capital
project is
far too large for the size of authority
that
we are it's quite right you know you've
got a 10 million pound
turnover um operation
and you know you're proposing to spend
three
three and a half times on
capital on you know on capital projects
it's it's a very um
adventurous um you know program to have
i mean
i wouldn't argue that it is too long
which is why i'm suggesting
that it should be cut i'd like to see
some other things cut out of it as well
to be perfectly honest with you but um
you know i don't think a zoom meeting is
uh long enough or the appropriate
setting to do
that but i'd certainly like to um you
know sit around the table and
have a good old chin wag about where we
could possibly save some money we you
know with others but
i think his i think his comment is is
absolutely correct i think it is too
large
thank you okay thank you councilman
councillor lock
yeah i was going to um bring the exact
one that councillor hicks has just
bought
but all these aspirational projects i
think they want to be scrapped
and i think that we should not accept at
this stage anymore
aspirational projects um and also
we perhaps could look at reducing our
discretionary
revenue services that might be another
avenue but i do disagree with council
bushby about the um borough center
um i'd think it's miles too late now to
withdraw from the project
i mean at the plans committee we passed
the new revised plans and everyone was
in favor of
aonb and people like that saying how it
would bring benefit to the area and for
the people that use it so i really do
think it's too late to pull out
that but i definitely think we should
get rid of any aspirational projects
councillor lever
thank you chair well very interested in
listening to the comments
i too agree that our capital program is
too large we've got far too much in
there
but i'll just take david back to closing
the
budget gap which is at seven
and the shortfall of the identified
there with the two options
i just wanted to ask on option two why
deleted the proposed income from cleave
wood
tadworthy and bridge buildings
because i i'm going to assume in the
next couple couple of years we'll
will realize those capital receipts
i think i was probably just alluding to
the uncertainty of any capital receipt
to be truthful
okay they're not always necessarily like
say the tab worthy receipt isn't
necessarily within our arena somebody
actually has to
buy it until it's bought and contracts
are exchanged
um it's not guaranteed okay thanks for
that david and the other thing was
extra costs of for the depot of 1.35
million i don't know i've never heard
what what what that
alludes to
the extra cost right
yeah i mean there's been some drift when
this originally was started i think the
message cost of the depot at the time
the report was written in january 2017
was circular about four million pounds
and then
we adrian included some build inflation
um a couple years later which added
another 1.4 million reflecting
the sort of tenders we'd experienced as
a council in the intervening time
and then obviously we've gone out to
actually secure sites and these are the
kind of values that are coming back to
us now
and that's why i referred to the
environmental centers to contrast that
with them
uh just a refuge depot so the
environmental center you would sort the
waste
and that would be onwardly transported
whereas a refuge depot
you'd park your vehicles and you'd
maintain your vehicles
but you wouldn't necessarily separate
the waste
that's why steve alluded to we need to
refresh that report
and give members what are the benefit
disadvantages of going down the
environmental centre route in the
you know the additional costs are from
the
exercise agents took in terms of
purchasing the site and the work he's
expecting to spend
on the two sites that are interested
thanks david you were breaking up a bit
there thanks for that
i mean for me when this council was
elected back in may last year
2019 there were two projects since then
that really
this council ought to have concentrated
on in my view and that
number one is the recycling waste and
recycling depo i don't call it an
environmental
center it's waste and recycling and
there's no point in having a new depo if
we're not going to do both
which is parking all our fleet of
vehicles on the site
maintaining them there and doing the
recycling as well because that's where
we're going to serve some money by doing
our own
recycling so you know i don't want to
see that reduced in any way
we've already identified borrowings
anyway from the public
loans uh public works loans board for
that
and the other one is the borough central
now councillor bush has always been
opposed to that
but that again is a good project for the
area
where i've been a bit uh lost in a way
is with the
linear defense works at westwood hall
now i understood that we were doing some
emergency works there which would be
integrated eventually
with the environment agencies
full-scale defense works down there and
yet we're now being
looking at one and a half million pounds
plus that we've got to find towards that
now
i don't think we've ever discussed not
in this council
one and a half million pounds towards
linear defense down at western
so that concerns me some of these things
seem to
be sleeping in slipping in with quite
big financial implications without us
having discussed them properly
i quite accept that we need some
emergency defense work done there
but we've not got any guarantee yet from
the environment
agency that or when they're going to do
the
proper defense works that are needed at
westwood hall
but for me there's just the two projects
you can drop
everything else the green the greenhouse
projects
down at river bank forget that i would i
would just forget that
we've spent a lot of money on authority
job over the last few years down
at riverbank and uh it is what it is and
we've got to live with it for now
but there are i certainly do not want to
see
any reduction and i'm beginning to get
concerned that we're not moving on fast
enough
with the new waste reset and recycling
depot
and i'm with councillor busby on that it
ain't gonna cost anything like what's in
the budget for it
if it's done properly thanks steve okay
thank you very much councillor but steve
i can see you it's going to come in here
so
please i was just going to assure cancer
launch
sorry councillor leather we are still
working on both those projects as shawn
said the borough center
has moved forward quite significantly um
we're
planning to bring a report
back to members alongside the budget
because all of these things uh tie up
together
on the environment center for the end of
january meeting
so david and richard and friend
the finance team are working on the
number crunching
currently um with a proposal then
councillor is
involving you as lead member so you can
see that
those details detailed proposals coming
forward
in time for uh the
cnr meeting at the end of january i th
oh sorry i think it's the first of
february actually
so that both of those things are
progressing just to assure you
um with respect to the the greenhouse
project it probably doesn't read
quite as well so obviously we know the
property team
are occupying uh what's called the
greenhouse on the
riverbank house site and i think we all
know that probably well past its
economic life
so part of what we're trying to do is
facilitate
the property and procurement team of
coming out of that building
into the rest of riverbank house and
there's also
work required in the old committee room
which is currently occupied by the it
team uh to do with the ear handling
systems in there but that's something
to be looked at in the new year
obviously we're not quite sure
how many staff will be working in the
building or working from home what will
happen to the reception area
and all of those kind of things so
there's quite a few things a bit of work
to do
on that area in terms of the the linear
defense works yes we are currently
doing work and that's doing work in line
with the the budget that's already
proposed
or already approved and that was in
advance
of the largest scheme
and adrian as he suggested that it might
cost somewhere up to three million pound
of which uh this council would have to
contribute
half and the as david mentioned earlier
the environment a
the environment agency the other half
obviously it's early again
early days in that so it's not just
something that's drifting into the
capital program
it's something that needs quite a
considerable amount of work
but it's just kind of forward planning
to make members aware
of things that are coming up thanks chad
very much counselor hurley please thank
you chair
can i just say that before we start
writing our projects um
they've all been discussed as far as
where at length by members and approved
by members
costs will vary from from time to time
we've got no controller over that
councilor hicks had many wise words to
say on that a short while ago so
um i endorsed virtually majority of what
he said there
um regarding the burroughs project i
think that should still go ahead that's
been a lot of uh words spoken about that
and as sean has rightly said
there's a fair bit of money probably
been spent on that already
we can't just pull a plug on that we
could cost us almost as much to do that
as it would do to abandon the project
which as we said council bushby's been
against
virtually from the start for his own
reasons i guess
we should still be looking at the um the
environmental center because
if we don't it will come back sometime
in the not too distant future with
climate uh
high on the agenda and it will cost us a
lot more i guess to revisit
sometime in a later stage but really i
think any projects we have on here
we shouldn't be taking any more on we do
have a very
um large capital project at the moment
capital projects to the moment
and we should concentrate on those maybe
look at some time as council bush we
said
maybe face-to-face meetings at that time
um which is far better than the zoom
meeting
to discuss where they can be pruned or
whatever but for the time being i think
we should just concentrate
on what we have and not bring any other
projects into the capital program
thank you chair very much hurley
councillor bushby then council of laws
please
thank you sir i i just want to say one
more thing about the environmental
center
as far as i'm concerned this is probably
the most important project that we've
that we've got and i don't want to see
the environmental center
lost um clearly that's that's that's not
good at all
but i think we need to be sensible here
the the most important thing
is this is the sighting the land when
you've got
a large enough piece of land which you
can develop
you do it in a modular way so the first
step
is to obviously construct a building
which is large enough with you know
some some future proofing as well so
that you can do
all of your vehicle maintenance et
cetera et cetera all of the operations
that we're currently doing in westcom
but at a later date when the finances
you know um
dictate that you can do that then you
can have your environmental
center so that you could do your
recycling of rubbish that's currently
done at bridgeworthy
and save money uh by doing that i
i totally get that i totally get that
but
to do it all in one here is going to
cost obviously a significant amount of
money and we haven't got that money at
the moment
so if we concentrate on doing this in a
modular way
as i said with the workshop so that we
can vacate
westcom depot which is totally
inadequate i don't know how
we've ever got away with it um you know
for so long
on a health and safety issue etc um but
when you know if we can if we can push
on with this project and get
the operation transferred out of westcom
at least western
can then be sold and redeveloped and
we'll get a capital receipt
from that because clearly you know when
littlejohn's co-yard is is developed
which is they've
you know they've got planning on and
clearly westcom will probably be
included in that larger scheme
so to me that's that's a that's a real
urgent one
but it's not going to cost anything like
the money
that you've got in the budget certainly
do the first finish you would spend
excluding buying the land once you've
actually got the site
you will not spend any more than a
million on developing that site
even a five-star vehicle workshop
with all the associated parking concrete
bays and everything like that
wash plants a million quick goals a hell
of a long way
nowadays and building it something of
that nature
thank you thank you much cancer laws
please
council laws you're muted
thank you chair sorry about that um i
just want to say to members that
that what has happened in westwood ho is
three successive um big spring tide
i mean the really big spring tides with
huge gales behind them and it is
literally
was almost trying to rip the pebble
ridge
away from the westwood hoe end and
it it's not a whim of adrian
and chris wilson to do this work they
knew that emergency works were going to
have to be done
but this the consequence of these three
gales is that the environmental agency
also stepped in and
uh the whole thing has had to be
accelerated
because as i've already explained with
70 hours is
at risk of of uh of flooding
but the works that they're doing
they're temporary is the wrong word for
it they're putting in huge rock armor
uh um sort of eight and ten ton boulders
and tying the pill ridge back to
westford home
but members should also be aware that
the linear defense planned
by the environmental agency which we
hope will be within the next year or two
is only for the first 120 yards of the
pebble ridge
the pebble ridge itself is what it is
a movable feast but and
my thanks goes to uh adrian and chris
wilson
who i don't think have had very much
lead because they've had to work up this
engineering
thing and arrange for huge stone stones
and bolts
do everything literally in a week or two
and i thank them very much
thank you chair very much council
councillors i'll take you to page 50.
the recommendations to take the full
council you've got
obviously number a with three points and
you've got b there with
five points would anybody like to make a
proposal or
a second day to go with that i went to
the meeting
i proposed chair is that proposed we
accept
a and b to cancer brenton yeah
i look forward to a future
yeah pass the buck this one is yes
but i think but i do think sorry that
all cancers should have some input into
this
no it definitely counts as brenton and
i'd i'd like to second that
proposal there because it is important
for orders council to discuss this
you know 36 members representing all
different
wards within the area and it is crucial
for us to discuss
as a full council any other councillors
like to
comment on this we've got proposing the
seconder that we accept the
recommendations on page 50
a and b um i'm going to go to the
vote there please thank you chair
councillor brenton for councillor bright
for councillor bushby uh against because
the borough center's there
councillor christie or councillor dart
for councillor hicks
for councillor hurley
or councillor james or
councillor laws or councillor locke
or councillor mcgough four
councillor wiseman
that's eleven four and one against chair
thank you very much okay councillors
the next item's item 14
which would be the exclusion of the
public uh but obviously this meaning
we devote to go into part two which are
part two item coming on
so i'd propose we go into part two and
i'll look for a second please
second case of brent a second can we go
to the vote again please
thank you chair councillor brenton board
councillor bright
councillor hurley or councillor james
or councillor laws
or councillor lock
councillor locke thank you councillor
mcguff
for councillor wiseman
thank you that's unanimous chair thank
you very much and
i will say good night to members of the
public thank you very much
this